hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter five of utilitarianism you
notice that you see John Stuart Mill
grappling with the notion of rights and
he talks about legal rights and moral
rights and you notice that he is
spending a good bit of discussion not
just analyzing the conception of what it
means to have a right but saying that
utilitarianism is going to by its very
workings honor what we think of as
rights now why is he so focused on that
a little bit of backstory his
predecessor Jeremy Bentham the original
articulator the originator in many
respects of what we call utilitarianism
understood in a quantitative sense had
said that rights were nonsense on stilts
that was the phrase that he used and
what he was talking about there were
legal rights whose enforcement turned
out to be bad for the community as a
whole to be bad for the aggregate of
people affected and this is still a
problem today when we see legal
decisions allowing certain persons or
corporations or the government to do
things which when we look at it we said
that's really bad policy or that's bad
decision-making because look at how it
affects everybody else the other
stakeholders so mill wants to say
utilitarianism is not going to end up
you know trampling on people's rights on
their legitimate rights and so how do we
understand rights it turns out there's
actually a couple different correlative
notions one of these is duty and another
one is the possibility of sanctioning
and he talks about this about midway
through this section so let's start with
the notion of duty he says that when we
think about what it means to have a duty
he says it's part of the notion in every
one of its forms that a person may
rightfully be compelled to fulfill it
Duty is the thing which may be exact it
from a person as one exacts a debt if
you have a duty to do X then somebody
should be able to tell you that you need
to do it it may not be legally
enforceable it might depend on what we
call public opinion or even as mill says
another possibility the person's own
conscience convicts him or her and says
you ought to be doing this when we could
think of all the different things that
mill talks about in terms of justice and
injustice like keeping promises treating
people and partially or in you know
equal in respects in which they are in
fact equal giving people what it is that
they deserve whether good or bad
honoring respecting rights all of those
things are possibly duties and mill says
that you can compel a person in one way
or another through some sort of sanction
to do that duty and he says by the way
we need to distinguish this from other
things there's other things which we
wish that people should do which we like
or admire them for doing or perhaps
dislike or despise them for not doing
but yet admit they're not bound to do
this is not a case of moral obligation
that is not a duty in any sort of strict
sense he says so you know I do have to
feed and clothe my children and I should
in fact look out for their welfare in
other respects but do I actually have to
show up at my kids recitals you know
because they invite me Mill would say no
there isn't actually a duty to do that
you know we're not going to call upon
the law to enforce that maybe your
conscience will bother you a bit but but
perhaps there's good reasons why you
don't make it to the to the concert of
the recital right whereas you know if
your kid is going without shoes or
medicine or not going to school there's
a real problem there there's some sort
of duty and duties have to do with not
doing her and some way injustice has to
do for Mill with harm so he goes on and
he tells us about this when we say that
a person has a right he says there there
are duties of per
but perfect obligation duties in virtue
of which a correlative right it resides
in some person or persons right so for
example if I have children the state
says that I need to educate them that
doesn't tell me exactly how I need to
educate them but it does say that they
need to be educated in some way they
could go to private school public school
may be homeschooled there could be all
sorts of different possibilities but I
do have to educate them and if I don't
do that I am violating their rights the
right to an education those all sorts of
other possible examples he talks about
you know depriving a person of a
possession breaking faith with them
treating them worse than they deserve or
worse than other people who have no
greater claims he says in each case the
supposition implies two things a wrong
and injustice that has done some
assignable person who is wronged
injustice mace has also be done by
treating a persons better than others
but the wrong is done in this case to
his competitors who are also persons who
have rights so he goes on and he says
that when we think about the notion of a
right residing in the injured person
what does that mean he says that it's
not a I've treated this not as a
separate element in the composition of
the idea and sentiment but as one of the
forms in which these these clothing each
other the elements are hurt to some
assignable person and a demand for
punishment society if we say that
somebody has a right we're saying that
society ought to enforce that right
society ought to punish or sanction in
some way the other person who has a duty
to respect that right now this could be
you know very singular I mentioned that
my children have a right to education
but somebody else's kid down the block
who has a right to education it's not
really my duty to provide them an
education is it it's my duty to provide
my children with an education
and if I if the neighbor if their kid
isn't going to school it's not like the
the social workers or you know Child
Protective Services are gonna come
knocking on my door to to sanction me
they're gonna sanction that guy down
there there are some things where we
have very very general rights right none
of us have the right to poison the water
supply that all of us drink from none of
us have the right to just you know light
a fire in a crowded theater or to yell
fire when there is no fire in a crowded
theater either as it turns out so
there's all sorts of things where you
know that maybe there's a whole bunch of
people have that duty or maybe that only
one person has that duty but society
ought to enforce that person's right
that's what it means to actually have a
right if I have a right to freedom that
means that if you try to kidnap me
somebody should step in whether it be
the police or whether it be in a public
sentiment or whether it be your own
conscience which probably won't be all
that effective if you are in fact
kidnapping me somebody ought to be
stepping in so Mill says that the idea
of the right includes a demand for
punishment he says these two things are
what we mean when we speak of violation
of a right we call anything a person's
right we mean that he has a valid claim
on society to protect him in the
possession of it either by the force of
law or that by by that of Education and
opinion if he has what we consider
sufficient claim to have something
guaranteed to him by society we say he
has a right to it if we desire to prove
that anything does not belong to him by
right
we think this done as soon as it's
admitted that society doesn't have to
take measures for securing it to him but
that he should provide it by his own
exertions so to use Mills previous
example I do have a right for example to
enter into economic competition with
other people and thereby to earn my
living I do not have a right to an
automatic one hundred thousand dollars a
year there's no you know society ought
to
provide that to me agreed upon by
everybody I there are some people who
think that everybody should get you know
a lot of money or something like that
but that's that's not agreed upon by the
totality of society so what is the
upshot of this for utilitarianism
utilitarianism when it's working well is
going to respect rights and it's going
to be involved in sanctioning well these
people who have duties to make sure
they're not violating other people's
rights notice to the last thing I want
to say that everybody not only is over
here but also over here we have
obligations towards each other by living
in society not only are you not supposed
to kill or defraud or slander me but I'm
not supposed to do that to you either so
we all have duties there are correlative
rights that correspond to those duties
there is a capacity for society to
sanction us in this this is the way the
utilitarians of Mills stripe do look at
rights so that they're not simply as
Bentham said nonsense on stilts
you